ultimately whatever you believe you got
to live it and it should lead to growing
and giving this is the thing that
changed my life when you desire to be a
role model for others it puts you into
that pocket of service in life
rise and shine it says special time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person but when you start your
day off with a powerful routine that
inspires you like watching one of these
videos it will change your life so let's
start your day off right together grab
your cup of coffee know that i believe
in you and get ready for a shot of
espresso from tony robbins
[Music]
i don't tell people to believe
spiritually but i believe that
ultimately whatever you believe you got
to live it and it should lead to growing
and giving
if you're growing you feel alive if
you're giving you feel ten times more
alive and i think if someone can
celebrate and give then that spiritual
state so to me those are the areas i
look at mastering you know business
for sure but it's the areas of life that
matter most and
most of where we spend our time doesn't
make people feel fulfilled that's why
the average person
is not fit and healthy the average
person is not in a relationship where
they have tremendous passion you know
i'm not a dummy i'm not a positive
thinker i know the truth the average
person is not successful in business the
average person is not earning what they
want to earn
but you know what very few people have
those things but a few do a few are
happy fulfilled spiritually alive
financially strong their business is
growing they have passionate love
affairs and i'm obsessed with finding
the few who do and find out what they do
different teaching to everybody learning
from myself and teaching everybody else
whenever you don't know what to do
the best thing you can do is model
success
find the person or the people who've
done the thing that you want to do
learn how they did it apply it to your
situation so you can achieve similar
results and get to your goal
otherwise you're constantly bouncing
around between idea to idea to idea to
idea constantly trial and error trial
and error trial and error and you might
run out of time and it might actually
get too late where if you can model
success the the biggest shortcut to
success is to model
find the people who've done it
understand how they did it apply it to
your life this is the thing that changed
my life
i i quit on my business partner i was 19
years old
me 20 at that point i quit on my
business partner
i was just tired of things not working i
was tired of the business being so slow
and sluggish and and
not getting results and making no money
i was tired of it i was
everything before that that i applied
myself to i got a result and here i was
trying trying every day trying showing
up to the same
place she went into my business partners
living room every day working from this
dining room table every day and just
not getting results
and i was tired of it so i quit
and then i woke up the next day and
realized i don't want to quit i can't
quit yet i can't quit it's
i'm gonna regret this
but i can't keep doing it the way i'm
doing it and so
the genius moment out of pure
desperation
was
somebody has done this before
i asked myself who has done this before
who has built a software company before
who's done that i'm trying to solve this
problem
i don't feel like i'm an idiot
although i kind of feel like
like an idiot right now because i'm
trying so many things
i know i'm not stupid somebody's done
this before can't be this hard who's
done this
and that's where i thought of bill gates
who started microsoft and
he's just one of many he could have been
anybody in software he was just the only
person i could think of at the time
and i learned his story and found out
how he did it and applied those
strategies through him through
partnership so i thought okay let me get
some partnerships
and i got my first deal i've said for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars
a little while after and
that changed everything for me that
changed the business that
that made me stay in it that gave me
hope that made me feel
not worthless that made me feel like
things were possible that gave me growth
in the company and it also gave me a
strategy for the rest of my life and
that whenever i don't know what to do
the best thing to do is to model success
now how do you do it how do you
practically apply it there's a couple
ways
okay the first is to actually meet the
people
so
whatever you're struggling with maybe
it's a business goal maybe it's a life
goal maybe it's a relationship goal
maybe it's a weight loss goal
you know somebody's done it so can you
go and meet them can you tell them your
story and go and meet them some will be
harder than others i didn't have a
connection to bill gates
[Music]
to go and ask him so that would have
been a lot more difficult but maybe
there was another software entrepreneur
in my city that can go meet or if it's
about relationships
who's the happiest person that you know
in a relationship who do you think is
the best father or
or mother or husband and wife and can
you go meet them and talk to them you
know how inspiring it would be for them
too i mean to
to say hey i
this might sound weird but
you're the happiest person i know
you're that you're the happiest person i
know
and i want to be happier in my life
do you have 25 minutes for a coffee
to
just talk about it
you know how much of an honor that'd be
for a lot of people
to really give back contribute serve
you're coming from a genuine place
you model different people for different
things right you can model steve jobs
for being a visionary but you probably
don't want to model his happiness or his
how he was as a father or a husband
right you go to different people for
that
so so one is can you actually meet
somebody can you actually connect with
them can you actually
can you actually find the time to have a
coffee with them two is what i call
aspirational mentors these are people
who you'll never meet
i'll never meet steve jobs uh i still
have a chance to meet bill gates
and ap giannini my favorite entrepreneur
of all time you know his past i'm never
going to meet him
but you can learn through their videos
through their books through their legacy
to their archives it's why i make these
videos i'm i'm
april 2000 now is my first video
you know we're a decade plus into this
and i'm still making videos because it's
so important to me to model success to
learn from the best i want to learn from
tony robbins i want to learn from jeff
bezos i want to learn from oprah winfrey
and i've met i've met tony
i haven't met jeff or oprah yet and
there's a lot of people on my list that
i haven't met yet but i'm still learning
from them
every day and even though i know tony
i'm not calling him up every day in st
tony give me some motivation today
but i'm getting it through the videos
that's why i make this for you so you
can be around the people
even if you don't know them by watching
their videos and just making it a part
of your daily routine it's important
it's not enough to just watch one video
on one day and get motivated every day
has to be part of your environment has
to be part of your daily routine every
single day and if if it's my videos i'm
humbled and honored to be a part of that
and if it's somebody else's videos great
but but put that into your daily routine
it's really really important to get you
to where you want to go
so the first are actual mentors you can
meet the second are aspirational mentors
and the third are are what i would call
community how can you join a community
of people who are like-minded so
whether it's movement makers that i have
or analytics i have especially movement
makers is focused on family and
community where
you're not in this alone it's all these
other people who are trying to build up
their business their movement their
impact and to realize that you've got
people around you to support you where
you say hey i want to do
a collaboration with somebody you got
people who want to help you who are
asking how they can serve you as opposed
to the
most of the people in your life who are
probably telling you that your ideas
aren't going to work so how can you join
a community whether it's movement makers
or something else how can you join a
community where
people are supporting you and you're
supporting them as well because when
you're around people who are doing stuff
guess what's going to happen you're
going to do stuff too
it's going to rub off on you
all of these things that we're talking
about all three strategies is being
around the people
who are doing the things that you want
to do
and it gives you the energy
the hope
the inspiration
and the strategies on how to actually go
and do the thing
so one it could be the actual people
that you go and meet for coffee and you
tell them
how much you respect them and want to
ask them a few questions
two watching videos of the people that
you respect and admire and want to think
like every day watch the videos every
day and then three join a community so
you actually have people who are with
you so that you don't feel alone so that
this isn't just you off on this crazy
adventure all by yourself because some
moments you'll feel like you don't need
anybody and you're off and crushing it
but there'll be lots of days where
you feel like you're in this by yourself
entrepreneurship is a super lonely game
you feel like you're alone and there's
nobody there to help you or support you
so having a community that you're a part
of really really makes a difference to
give you the extra
again hope inspiration as well as
strategies to keep going whenever you
don't know what to do your model success
your model success
it is the shortcut you still have to do
the work but at least you're doing the
work with a roadmap at least you're
doing the work with a compass to guide
you to show you the direction as opposed
to doing the work that's what i did in
my first business running in circles
trying a million different things trying
to find a way to make it happen
and just not having the right strategy
so it's working but not getting results
if you want to get results you work hard
and you work smart
and the working smart comes from
modeling success
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you just get motivated when you
watch a video like this you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
are a bunch of action takers it has to
happen so here's how you do it when you
actually create a plan when you write
down what time what place where you're
actually going to take action your
number jumps from 35 to 91 chance of
following through and when you commit to
other people like leaving a comment down
below your number jumps to 95 chance of
following through i want that for you so
believe nation your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week i'm going to
take one of your comments and feature it
in a future video so i can celebrate you
let me know in the comments below also
if you want to have more self-confidence
and self-belief i've created a free
program to help you get it the sign says
it can take up to 254 days of
consecutive action to build a new habit
so i'm going to send you an unlisted
video for free every day for 254 days to
move your self belief and self
confidence forward to sign up for free
check the link in the description below
so if you want to change your life my
friends you got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming
today
what creates marketing is when you don't
just market but you add value to people
if you want to feel in purpose one way
to do that is to recognize
the kids are watching to recognize your
family is watching to recognize the
community is watching the neighborhood
is watching the world is watching us
right now history is taking note there
is a scorecard happening right now based
on how we are all showing up and for
some people that terrifies me because
like oh my gosh we're sharing up
terribly not me how about you how are
you showing up
the one of the greatest things i've ever
noticed from the exceptional people i
work with and coach i mean like this is
like amazing people if i'm i'm training
a uh you know an oprah winfrey and her
team or i am you know talking to you
know some of the most
like powerful influencers in the world
or i'm talking with other people who are
just like
so we're all amazed by guess what they
always reveal a desire to be a role
model for others
when you desire to be a role model for
others it puts you into that pocket of
service in life
it makes you go oh my gosh
i i want to not just live the best of
who i am that's part of being a role
model but i want to live the best of who
i am
because i want to give others permission
to do that themselves i want to share my
authentic voice so others can share
their authentic voice i want people to
see me volunteering because i want
people to go volunteer i want people to
see me being kind because i want people
to be and live when we're in a kind
world that is the role
model mindset
you know and i so hope for you i i i so
hope for you that you will adopt the
role model mindset this year if you want
another amazing tony robbins video check
it out right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
i'll see you there everybody wants a
better quality of life everybody wants
life to be greater but almost all of us
get stuck at times where something stops
us something prevents us from doing
something that we really are capable of
doing